klaus wregling the boss of the european
stability mechanism came to answer mep's
questions
the european stability mechanism is a
fund of 700 billion euros for eurozone
members in difficulty
one year after its launch the esm is
assessing its policy of bailout with
conditions in other words austerity
island portugal greece and spain have
fallen strongly
as a consequence these countries have
improved their competitiveness and
current account deficits are
disappearing everywhere
these results show that conditionality
works
with 84 million people living under the
poverty line in europe and 26 million of
them are unemployed meps debated the
economic crisis in the petitions
committee
ngos and members of civil society
represent the weakest among us and the
victims of the crisis
less austerity a more social europe and
a new treaty are the main demands of
petitioners we have a one-sided economic
treaty with a monetary union but we need
more solidarity we need as well as
social union and we need participation
of the people we need a democratic
procedure
for a new treaty and that is a new
convention a third convention to
elaborate a new european treaty
greater respect for human rights mdps
meeting the foreign affairs committee
are assessing the stockholm programme
they've raised alarm over the poor
conditions for migrants arriving in the
eu they're asking for more firmness to
be shown towards third countries that
violate human rights
necessary
national
a